now an update to a story we first told
you about yesterday Air Force One is an
iconic symbol of the American presidency
but it might be getting a makeover
president Trump reportedly wants to
update the design on the next version of
the jet with a bolder and quote more
American look the current colors date
back to the early 1960s ten Presidents
before mr. Trump traveled with the same
design Kris Van Cleave is outside the
White House with how the president is
personally invested in the next
generation of Air Force One Chris good
morning well good morning and don't
forget the president used to own an
airline and has his own 757 so he's no
stranger to deciding on the look of an
aircraft and certainly he's not afraid
to shake things up in Washington so
maybe it's no surprise he'd look at
making changes to the flying White House
Air Force one arrived in London looking
as regal and presidential as it has for
decades but that iconic robin's egg blue
could be about to fly off into the
sunset president Trump is said to be
mulling a jumbo jet sized makeover for
the next-generation Air Force 747s do
sometime after 2020 that could include a
red white and blue paint scheme over the
years that plane has become the most
iconic aircraft in the world then Ken
Walsh wrote Air Force One a history of
the presidents and their planes he's
perfectly entitled to make changes in
the current design the question is he's
really messing around with history here
Howie Franklin was the steward on Air
Force one for five presidents the idea
of changing the planes look is personal
well I flew on Air Force one for 18
years and still to this day when I see
Air Force One even on TV but when I see
it on an event if I'm there alive I did
Pingel when the new 747s that become Air
Force one when the president is aboard
arrived mr. Trump would not be the first
commander-in-chief to change up the
presidential plane
President Truman replaced Roosevelt's
nondescript sacred cow for the
independence painted to resemble an
eagle John F Kennedy with the help of
first lady Jackie Kennedy and design
genius Raymond Loewy took the plane from
this to the one we know today so Kennedy
an airplane that built the brand of the
presidency it's all part of this whole
pattern of him trying to create increase
the visibility of the presidency has an
active office and as a glamorous office
when President Reagan ordered the
current Air Force Ones the look stayed
the same 11 presidents have now circled
the globe on a plane
Camelot created I think it'd be very
difficult to make the next one look
better but it's possible another of the
reported changes under consideration a
bigger better bed on the new planes the
current one is a bit like a sleeper sofa
and Alex no one really likes sleeping on
a fold-out wow that's a pretty iconic
design that Air Force One thank you
Chris